Kevin Millar makes League Baseball
Network analyst won the World Series
with the Red Sox and Oh for MLB Network
airing 12 consecutive hours of live
Opening Day coverage you can watch Kevin
and Chris Rose co-host intentional talk
weekdays at 5:00 Eastern throughout the
season and we welcome back Kevin Millar
Kevin good morning how are you what do
you remember about your first opening
day man I tell you what it's the best
day ever
I mean really I mean baseball fan on
baseball fan player but just the I guess
the adrenaline and the nerves and the
excitement and the and just hoping they
don't hit it to me at first base I don't
make an error and the first opening day
I got a chance to start was when I had a
chance to beat out Derek Lee in spring
training he's just gorgeous man he's six
foot five sweet as humne in the world
he's 21 we just got from the Kevin Brown
trade from San Diego and I'm like Crash
Davis I'm 52 years old with a bad body
five foot ten I say six foot and I beat
him out my first opening day I'm all
fired up and I literally got two at-bats
they put them in for defensive
replacement I think in the fifth inning
oh okay good job I'm done did you ever
have a great opening day no day on my
birthday
never had a great opening you know what
I take that back I homered in Baltimore
against the Detroit Tigers Sean Casey
and Jim Leyland mighty Tigers after
doing the Ray Lewis kind of come out
when their introduction I was challenged
by Corey Patterson and he goes you won't
do ray lewis i goes done so i stepped
out and i had this little kid and i said
it's good over here uncle Kevin's got
this and I did the Ray Lewis dance
really a bad version of it but and I end
up homering the next my first at-bat so
that was cool I thought that was pretty
cool day how many teams can win it all
this year seven seven teams something
you look at it yeah I mean we're gonna
all go to camp start the year off
everybody starts to the same page
there's excitement Cincinnati it's
exciting we've had some new players we
look around the league but really seven
teams you know there's some powerhouses
and I think then it gets kind of like
okay where are they at financially are
they rebuilding or we trying to build
our farm system I mean Detroit Tigers
are going to probably have the longest
year of anybody that's what if that's
the next question but there's just some
great divisions also I mean the National
League East flip a coin bootie got Nats
Phillies Braves come back and do it Matt
so they can be way better yes but you
know we asked the question today or how
many of those four teams are gonna be in
the playoff hunt last week of the season
what would you say that
well how many your of the seven teams
here named them we got Yanks and Sox
immediately you got Houston you got the
Dodgers and then I would say that
Nationals you could put in that category
or the Phillies good enough right now
yeah the excitement is and they still
got money to spend if they need to add
something like David Robertson helps
them so I'm gonna put them in that
category I don't think the Mets are good
enough I don't think the Braves starting
staffs good enough so I wouldn't put
them in it yet
but I would say Dodger Sox Yanks Houston
can Terry Francona in the Cleveland
Indians make a little run with their
losses you know and a few teams in the
central let's not forget about the
Brewers probably one of my favorite
teams I think and they're very
intriguing I don't know where they're
gonna be out starting rotation wise but
that bullpen
it's nasty so you can put the Cardinals
and the Brewers in those mixes to the
2019 Major League Baseball poll the
athletic had their beat writers talked
to as many players as they could and
about a third of the league overall
including players from all 30 teams so
they had a wide range of topics they're
the most intimidating pitcher in the
game who did they pick second not here
sir yes
Aroldis Chapman was third on that list
the most intimidating hitter in the game
ooh Mike Trout yeah I would have gone
Aaron judge as far as intimidation but
Mike Trout 40% said him then it was
Aaron Judge JD Martinez
and Giancarlo Stanton yeah intimidating
you're right intimidating judge is the
specimen I still think though good
pitchers think they can get those
intimidating hitters out I think the
scrappy hitter is like a Dustin Pedroia
and his prime you know those are the
toughest outs they're cheaters but I
think yeah if you're using the word
intimidating you're right judge would
probably be more intimidating than trout
traps and that big thick neck day looks
like a tailback who was the most
intimidating hitter in your time Gary
Sheffield I think he was the most
violent in prime when he's come up with
the Marlins I said he actually stole his
suede shoes but he gave him to me but I
stole a mouse locker so I just want to
be Gary Sheffield I was like the wiggle
wiggle but he was violent Danny you
never took an at-bat off what about the
moment picture wise yeah yeah Rainey
Johnson I mean one is ugly nasty slider
he's six foot pan he's twirling his
flavor saver on the mound over this
black glove he can't barely see his eyes
yeah it was just it was a battle and I
went four for four the first game
against him and homered and I'm like
this is amazing whoever I thought I
owned rain Johnson Marissa Meyer you
know seemed he struck me out thirty
times he doesn't strike me as somebody's
gonna take kindly to going for four four
including a home run off of him and you
meet the next time right you see who's
this guy we got like 58 wins with the
Marlins he answered get caught slippin
in the hitters count and I home off a
fastball I get a couple of doubles ok
good life's good I don't think I've
contacted for the next seven years the
most underrated player in the game is
underrated man it's you know Andrew
Bennett ND i think this kid's a batting
title champion waiting to happen I just
think he does a lot of great things on
the baseball field but you have mookie
and you have JD Martinez you have Xander
Bogaerts but I would say Andrew Bennett
dandy just watch it little guy plays the
game the Royal I think he's him really
buddy yeah he gets lost a little bit in
mouki shadow but he's he's a talented
kid the most underrated player in the
game according to the players in the
game plays for the national
ooh rendang yeah
Oh was it yeah you look at some of his
numbers I mean yeah that's a good one I
like that one
Paul Goldschmidt God he was runner-up
here for underrated you know what you
know what's underrate about him Danny
and I'm gonna tell you he is a
tremendous bass dealer check the numbers
on buck he stole more bags than Mike
Trout over the last few years like he
runs and when he runs he's safe he's
smart
so just locking on Paul Goldsmith
stealing 20 bags accidentally but but
he's not underrated he's just under
covered I think there's a difference in
that because Goldschmidt was great with
the Diamondback he could win the MVP in
the National League this year of course
it's almost like the Mike Trout scene
right you don't hear much about them
because there's such sweethearts of
human beings they ban the West Coast so
there's not a whole lot right you just
kind of like okay they're great players
great players so that's where I think
the underrated aspect of it gets he
won't be underrated in the central and
the Cubs and the Cardinals rivalry and
you know Brewers so you'll you'll get a
chance to really lock in on some Paul
Goldsmith but what would a guy what a
player Kevin Millar from the Major
League Baseball Network and former World
Series champ with the Red Sox joining us
the most overrated player according to
the poll on the Atlantic let me guess
they said Bryce Harvey has 62 percent no
it is funny though we love to hate we
love what we do
everybody was a hate but the most
overrated player I mean 10 he he hasn't
locked in 100 RBIs but once you know
he's got an MVP you can't just they
don't give those out so it's hard to say
overrated when you got an MVP under your
belt right I mean how do you how do you
say that I know he won one MVP but the
attack he gets more attention it feels
like than any other player in baseball
and because of that he can't live up to
that hype he can't live up to the
coverage therefore you know you're going
to by proxy be overrated you're right
it's like you you you are a wonderful
looking young man
phenomenal you shoot hoops thank you you
can't live up to who Danny Patrick
really is there at the end of the day
you love golf you love sports you do a
great job of what you do
Bryce Harper you're right there's gonna
be three hundred thirty million dollars
and let's just say Bryce Harper gets off
to a rough six weeks
how's that going to go in the Philly
media Oh in April okay the the honeymoon
is not gonna over under honeymoon is
three months there in Philadelphia how's
you guys doing silly I'll tell you how
he's gonna do hopefully for his sake he
gets off to a good start cuz I don't
care who you are I mean I - Edgar
Renteria was crying in my arms in Boston
in April when he hit 180
Edgar Renteria has done a lot in this
game but at that point came over from
st. Louis so my point being is that the
East Coast media-wise can absolutely
damage you if you get to a slow start
and that and then they could build you
up to be Errol Smith once he starts
hitting 4:30 so hopefully for Bryce he's
been amazing at opening days and he owns
Julio Terron who he's facing so we'll
see what happens there alright what
concerns do you have about the Dodgers
starting staff health-wise rich he'll
need him on the mound need the curveball
working without blisters Walker Buehler
I need the train wheels
pulled off I think he's a special kid
changing of the guards almost with
Clayton Kershaw - Walker Buehler
I need Clayton Kershaw to throw 175
million about 130 Ryu needs to stay
healthy he's really good when he's
healthy so I would say that Kenley
Jansen back in somewhat scratching in my
head because I don't see the 97 anymore
I see 91 to 93 cutters watch that but
overall that's a good ballclub and Dave
Roberts I love I shower with them many
times Danny we've even talked about Curt
Schilling the showers there's been a
great interview I know chillin the worst
body you ever showered with you know
what be a worse superstar body I've ever
showers there's been some bad bodies in
the middle release situations doesn't
make it bad people I want to get that
clear
I have a bad body but Curt Schilling's
by far the worst body as a superstar
Matty Albers who I absolutely love
pitches in bullpen relief with the
Brewers phenomenal but in Baltimore
wonderful body in the shower a little
loose you know a little bit like an
avocado
Chris Rose is shaped like an avocado or
now wow I've never showered with them
have you ever showered like with the
group of men no no that's a weird
question but have you ever done that
like yes yeah yeah got it
yes kind of fun like I always say like I
feel bad cuz people like oh my god what
goes on behind the scenes like think
about showering with twenty guys it's
like you're four years old guys are
throwing soap they're making fun of you
they're turning your water cold the hot
and then you walk out you're like dad
hey honey how are you you're a husband
you were just sour with 20 dudes you
know I'm saying thank you that hot water
is on you look down like whoa whoa over
the line over the line we used to cover
up the drain with paper towels and then
you could slide up and down the shower
stall in high school yeah I wish
everybody a shower with twenty dudes and
then there's all kinds of stuff going on
you know your eyes stay up here stop
looking down there I'm Irish okay stop
not nice have fun play nice with Chris
Rose tensional talk weekdays at 5:00
Eastern throughout the season on MLB
Network thank you Kevin all right thanks
brother that's Kevin Malone Major League
Baseball Network analyst they got 12
consecutive hours of opening day
coverage today for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
you